I do Taylor being the acting returning
officer at the election of a member of
Parliament's for the words Lee and
Echols south parliamentary constituency
held on the 8th of June 2017 give notice
that the number of votes recorded for
each candidate is as follows Kate
Clarkson Liberal Democrats 1087 Tom
Dylan Green Party 842 Barbara Mary Keely
Labour Party 26,000 and 36 Ian David
Lindley the Conservative Party candidate
17,000 667 the number of ballot papers
rejected was as follows once of the
official mark 15 voting for more than
one candidate 26 writing all mark by
which the votes could be identified 0
unmarked or wholly void from 70 76 the
total number of ballot papers rejected
was 117 the total number of votes cast
was 40 5757
the total number of votes cast
represents 62% of the registered
electors the majority of 8,000 379 I
hereby declare that Barbara Mary Keely
is elected as Member of Parliament
a necklace out parlimentary consistently
I would like to thank the returning
officer the counting staff and the
election staff for dealing with the
challenges in the case of the election
staff of a snap general election not one
they had months to plan but a snap one I
would also like to thank the police I
know they have been working very much
beyond the normal working hours since
the terrible events in Manchester and
thank you for that work today on polling
day I want to make a special thank you
to all who worked on my campaign
particularly my team in walk done have
been working seven days a week
Emily Megan my wonderful agent Sarah
Hall elections are not one just in the
campaigns they are one in hard work and
helping year-round thousands of people
who have often got complex and difficult
issues I have been honored to be the MP
for Worsley since 2005 and forwardly
necklace out since 2010 and I am proud
that my constituents have put their
faith in me again to carry on
representing them I am proud to be a
Labour MP a party which stands for the
many not the few
[Music]
we fought a good campaign we fought a
brilliant campaign on policies which
people in this constituency have valued
given that I have worked nationally on
Social Care I was very pleased that that
issue came to the fore in this campaign
it rarely does people have shown in the
way that they voted how much the issue
of Social Care matters as well as things
like free school meals school budgets
and tuition fees or vital we need an end
to austerity we need an end to the
erosion of our public services through
cuts and particularly the NHS can I say
I think we were all so proud of the job
done by sword Royal with the victims of
the terror attack they did a brilliant
job but we cannot we cannot just rely on
the goodwill of nurses and doctors to
provide that excellent care to do all
the extra that we expect of them after
an attack like that they deserve to be
better paid and they deserve to be
better supported and our other staff who
provide amazing public services they
deserve to be better paid and they
deserve to be better supported as do all
the staff as I say I will continue to
work very hard for everyone in the
constituency with the the backing I know
of excellent Labour councillors in sore
furred and an amazing team that I have
in both warden and Westminster thank you
[Applause]
you